- Hey, everyone out there.
Welcome in to "Market Takes."
It's another exciting
edition of "Market Takes."
Today we are looking ahead to the week.
There's no big data release
that just came out this morning,
but we are gonna look ahead
and talk about all the things
that are gonna be coming up this week
to get you ready for what's coming
so you can jumpstart your week
prepared, ready to go, hit the ground.
It is Monday, 10:00 AM Eastern
Time here in New York City,
and I am Dion Rabouin, the
host of "Market Takes,"
reporter at "The Wall Street Journal."
Thank you so much for being with us.
Look, here's what we've
got going on right now.
We've got this global banking crisis
that everyone is talking
about globally, really,
as it's a global banking crisis.
Here in the US,
you've got this thing going
on with Silicon Valley Bank.
Big news on that today, we'll
get into that in just a sec.
Also coming up this week,
we've got Fed Vice Chair
for Supervision Michael Barr
is testifying before the
US Senate and the House.
We've got ECB,
European Central Bank
President Christine Lagarde.
She's gonna be speaking on Tuesday
ahead of some very important
and key eurozone inflation data.
We've also got an update
on the Fed's discount borrowing window
and global central bank holdings.
That's gonna be big this week.
Also, New York Fed
President John Williams,
he is one of the most influential folks
on the Federal Open Markets Committee.
That's gonna be big.
They are all of course
going to be talking about
these banking issues that have really,
it started with Silicon Valley Bank,
or maybe it started a little bit earlier
with Signature Bank, but
this has had global ripples.
So everyone's gonna be talking about that,
it's on folks' mind,
and we're gonna tell you
what to watch out for,
what you need to know.
Also, latest data on
recession expectations.
We also get some updates on inflation,
so we're gonna get The Conference Board's
Consumer Sentiment Index on Tuesday,
or sorry, The Conference Board's
Consumer Confidence Index on Tuesday.
And then on Friday, we get
the University of Michigan
Consumer Sentiment Index.
That's coming out.
We also are gonna get
Case-Shiller home prices.
That's for January.
That comes out a little
bit earlier in the week.
And the US monthly home price,
the US Monthly Housing
Prices Index on Tuesday,
along with pending home sales on Wednesday
that you're gonna definitely
wanna watch out for,
because housing is a major
piece of this inflation picture.
And we will talk about
the state of business.
We're getting advanced
economic indicators,
another update on the GDP report,
as well as the Personal
Consumption Expenditures Report,
PCE, the Fed's favored gauge of inflation,
that's coming out this week
along with a report on US profits.
So let's talk really quickly
about the global banking crisis,
where we are, what's happening with that.
The latest news this morning
is the FDIC Tweeting,
"Today we entered into an agreement
with First Citizens Bank and Trust Company
to purchase and assume
all deposits and loans
of Silicon Valley Bridge Bank."
That's just what happened
when the FDIC took over
Silicon Valley Bank,
renamed it Silicon Valley Bridge Bank,
that's what's happening now.
First Citizens is a North
Carolina based bank.
They're gonna take over
all 17 branches of Silicon Valley Bank.
That's big news.
First Citizen stock is up 43% at the open.
This will be the best
day for First Citizens
in a very, very long time.
FDIC estimating the cost of the failure
of Silicon Valley Bank to
its deposit insurance fund
will be approximately $20 billion.
This move right now is
sending markets higher.
We're seeing global stocks up right now.
The DAX in Germany filling some relief
on some of these Deutsche Bank worries.
That's up big.
The S&P, the Dow, NASDAQ,
all up, a little under 1% right now,
but moving in a positive direction.
Remember, Credit Suisse
was taken over by UBS
and Deutsche Bank shares
really started to tumble.
Well, Germany's DAX Index,
which is their benchmark stock index
equivalent to basically
the S&P or the Dow here,
that's up big today, almost
about 3% earlier today.
Now, how did we get here?
We put out a report last week,
or a couple weeks ago it
might have been at this point,
on how Silicon Valley Bank's collapse
is impacting the overall
global banking sector.
Make sure you check that out.
We're gonna have that linked
so you can easily find that
when you're watching on VOD.
But check that out.
Basically, the big problem
was Silicon Valley Bank
made some poor decisions
in not hedging a lot of
its bets on treasuries,
but the big problem for
the overall banking sector
is Silicon Valley Bank wasn't
doing anything different
than what other banks are doing.
A lot of the assets,
basically any asset that you
purchased about a year ago
is gonna be worth less than
what it was at that point now.
So a lot of these banks,
when people are returning and saying,
"Hey, I want my money
back, I need my deposits,"
they're saying, "We don't have it.
We've put this in these assets
and these assets are worth less
than what we paid for them now,
so if we were to sell them,
we'd have to sell at a loss,
and then we would have less money
than what we got in deposits."
That's a big problem,
and if there were runs on all these banks,
the big five, US Bank,
Wells Fargo, JP Morgan,
Bank of America those guys
generally would be all right.
And Citigroup, you throw them in there.
But for other banks, there
really isn't a bright light.
If they get bank runs,
they're not gonna be able to fulfill those
because the things they've invested in,
whether that's mortgages,
whether it's mortgage-backed
securities, US treasuries,
which are very safe, have all
lost value over the past year.
And treasuries especially,
the price of treasuries
has sunk significantly.
So that gets us to the role of the Fed,
because the Federal Reserve
has really stepped in here
to play a big role making
sure all this happens.
We talk about the Fed a lot,
and the Fed has injected a lot
of liquidity into the system.
Fed Vice Chair for
Supervision Michael Barr
will be testifying, as well as
FDIC chair Martin Gruenberg,
and Treasurer Under Secretary
for Domestic Finance
Nellie Liang will testify
at a pair of hearings,
Senate Banking Committee on Tuesday,
and the House Financial
Services Committee on Wednesday.
So those are gonna be big.
You're also gonna watch out for
in terms of the overall
picture for central banks,
European Central Bank President Lagarde,
she's gonna speak on Tuesday,
and then on Friday, you get
eurozone inflation figures.
Now, that number was 8.5%,
you saw 8.5% year-over-year inflation
in the eurozone for the last month.
That was back in February.
For March, if that number is up above 8%,
that's gonna signal that
inflation is not falling.
Remember, the ECB raised rates
50 basis points at their last meeting.
That's a very big hike for them.
Remember, rates were negative
just about a year ago,
and this increase now is they're
moving at a very fast pace
and saying, "We're not worried about
this banking sector thing.
We're gonna keep raising rates
because we have to fight inflation."
If inflation comes in hot this week
on that number for eurozone inflation,
you could see more worries about
the overall banking system,
the health of the economy,
all that good stuff.
On the other side of the
coin, here in the US,
the Federal Reserve has taken
some pretty significant steps
to try to shore up the banking sector.
And I wanna throw something
up here on your screen
to just kind of illustrate
what we have seen from
the Federal Reserve,
and the overall state of things
and how the Fed has operated.
Now, you're seeing that, what
you see is starting at 2020,
the Fed just buying up everything,
what we called QE infinity.
And that number kinda goes up and up,
and then it starts to come down
as the Fed starts raising rates,
implementing quantitative
tightening or QT.
Basically, not buying any more bonds
and actually letting the
ones that they own mature
and not buying them back.
But then at the edge of the
right side of your screen,
you see that line that
goes basically straight up?
That's what's happened
over the last couple weeks
because the Fed has had
to try and pour some water
on this financial crisis
or this banking crisis,
and that's added them add a lot more
to their balance sheets.
And we're seeing that number pick up
back towards the $9 trillion figure,
which is where the Fed
had purchased bonds,
not even, let's say five, six months ago,
before they started
quantitative tightening.
So wanted to put that up there
just to illustrate the
overall rate of things
and how this banking crisis has adapted.
We'll hear from Fed Vice Chair, or Fed,
excuse me, New York Fed President
John Williams on Friday,
and he's gonna be kinda the
most influential speaker
that we'll hear from after
the Fed's meeting last week.
Listen, let's talk inflation
and recession worries,
because those are obviously
on people's minds.
We get The Conference Board
and the University of Michigan's
Consumer Confidence Index
and the Consumer Sentiment Index.
Those are both coming out this week.
A little bit about the
difference between the two,
The Conference Board is more about
how people feel about business.
It's more about how folks
are thinking about the state of business,
how easy it's to do business,
how difficult what they think,
how they think businesses are doing,
whereas the University of
Michigan survey basically asks,
"Hey, how are you feeling?
How's your financial house?
How is everything, it going for you?"
And when we look at those,
really the most important
one I think for consumers,
and for what folks are gonna be doing,
where they're gonna
continue to spend money,
whether they're gonna keep buying things
is the University of Michigan.
That has been trending up this year,
but we've seen some worrisome indicators.
And also, how much has this banking crisis
weighs down the consumers.
So wanna put a chart up here
on your screen really quickly.
It's the University of Michigan's
Consumer Sentiment Index.
You see it kinda went
down going into 2023,
but over the last couple
months, we've seen that pick up.
And will we see that continue?
That's the big question.
We are seeing a big decrease
from The Conference Board
saying the second consecutive
month their index decreased.
This is different from the
University of Michigan Index
which is up on your screen.
Wanna take that down
because I think we've
illustrated our point there
with the University of Michigan,
but The Conference Board
saying the decrease reflected
large drops in confidence
for households age 35 to 54.
Those are the most important household.
Those are prime earners,
AKA prime workers.
And for households earning
$35,000 a year or more.
A lot of confidence being lost there.
That's big, and that's
gonna make a difference.
Also, housing.
Housing has played a big role
in the overall inflation story
because the Fed can have a
direct impact on housing.
By raising rates, they
make it more expensive
to get a mortgage,
for companies to borrow
to maybe get some of that
commercial real estate.
Well, wanna throw another
chart up here on your screen
and that is existing home sales.
Now, you're seeing the
number of existing homes
purchased each month decline,
decline, decline, decline,
until up last month, you see
that number rising higher.
That's a 14.5% increase year-over-year
from the previous year.
Now, what does that mean?
It means folks are still
going out buying homes,
taking out a mortgage,
doing exactly the opposite
of what the Fed wants
when it's raising rates
to try and get the economy
and trying to get inflation under control.
Well, that's not a great
sign for the overall economy
because it means the
Fed may have to do more,
means what it's doing isn't working.
So that chart just kind of illustrates
what we're seeing from
overall housing purchases.
You saw housing slowing down,
prices were coming down.
Well, prices are starting to pick back up.
We will get some more
data on from Case-Shiller.
They're gonna come
with the January home
price index on Tuesday,
and the pending home
sales Index on Wednesday.
That says how many people
are signing contracts
before they actually buy the house,
but when you go under contract.
This report is gonna
tell us how many people
are getting under contract
in the last month,
and if that number is picking up,
well, that shows you
overall across the board,
housing is picking up,
people are spending,
they're doing the opposite
of what the Fed wants.
May mean the Fed has to be more vigilant
and may have to raise rates
even in the face of this banking crisis.
That's what all this means.
And then finally, we get
the PCE report producer,
or I'm sorry, purchasing expenditures-
Ooh, I'm saying the whole word wrong.
Let me start again.
The Commerce Index, the
Commerce Department is going to
release the Personal
Consumption Expenditures Index.
That's the price index,
basically the Fed's
favored gauge of inflation.
It was at 5.4% last month.
Economists are expecting
that to fall below 5%.
If it doesn't, the Fed may
have more work on its hands,
and that may mean a tougher economy,
making it tougher on banks,
and we could see more worries
about the banking sector
pumping through Wall Street
and start to get folks worried.
Again, we're gonna get a lot
of information this week.
This is a big week.
We also get a report on
corporate profits on Thursday.
Last week, we saw durable goods orders
fall for the second month in a row.
Durable goods are things
like cars, washers, dryers,
refrigerators, air
conditioners, stuff like that.
We also get the Advanced
Economic Indicators
from the Census Bureau for February.
That's gonna be your big report.
Watch out for that.
Listen, this is "Market Takes."
We are looking ahead at the week.
That's what you got coming
up for you this week.
I hope I jump-started
your week really well,
and I appreciate y'all
tuning in for "Market Takes."
I hope you will be back,
'cause we will do it again
right here Monday morning
on "Market Takes."
I hope to see you there next time.